bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag depuis
le 11 mai saint quentin en yvelines a
amorcé un déconfinement progressif
écoles transports commerces entreprises
loisirs comment ça se passe au quotidien
ou fait points c'est parti
[Musique]
comme partout en france
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a amorcé le déconfinement le 11
mai dernier le déconfinement à était
plus je pense plus qu'attendu surtout
plus tôt dans la population plus jeune
et on peut comprendre parce que c'est
c'est compliqué en fonction aussi de si
vous habitez en maison où vous avez un
jardin ou quand vous êtes dans des
logements quand même le plus petit
c'était vraiment extrêmement compliqué
[Musique]
le retour progressif des français sur
leur lieu de travail va de pair avec la
reprise des transports
une charte du voyageur affiché dans
toutes les gares invite les usagers à
respecter les gestes barrière corps du
masque et attestation de l'employeur
sont obligatoires aux heures de pointe d
accès unique ont été instaurées en gare
de saint quentin en yvelines montigny le
bretonneux par la place charles de
gaulle en gare de plaisir grignon par la
gare routière sur le réseau un siège sur
deux est disponible pour respecter les
distances des gels hydroalcooliques sont
à la disposition de tous côté bus le
réseau fonctionne à 100%
là encore le port du masque est
obligatoire
les bus sont désinfectés quotidiennement
du gel hydro alcoolique est aussi à
disposition pour celles et ceux qui
voudraient éviter les transports la
vélostation a rouvert ses portes depuis
le 27 avril
ces temps ci la location de vélos
électriques est en forte hausse pour les
réparations des vieilles bicyclettes
la région offre un chèque de 50 euros
ainsi qu'une petite formation de remise
à niveau à la conduite du deux roues des
400 km d'itinéraires cyclables du
territoire saint quentinois devrait
bientôt s'étendre grâce au plan vélo de
l'agglomération en tout 45 km de pistes
supplémentaires notamment sur les
départementales 6000 gilet jaune et
brassards seront bientôt distribuées
pour plus de sécurité avec le
déconfinement de nombreux commerces ont
rouvert d'autres malgré tout demeure
fermé comme dans le secteur de la
restauration comme pour les entreprises
le territoire réfléchi
plan de soutien pour aider ces commerces
de proximité
[Musique]
pendant le confinement le territoire a
impulsé un groupe facebook dédié aux
commerçants et aux agriculteurs ceux ci
n'ont pu signaler leur ouverture et leur
initiative à travers une carte
interactive
une action qui a permis aux saint
quentinois de trouver des adresses
utiles pour consommer local et soutenir
l'activité économique de proximité
par contre c'est très compliqué pour les
commerciaux autres 1er août et les
former parce qu'ils ont perdu du chiffre
d'affaires
c'est que 51 avec la région se
mobilisent pour un fonds de solidarité
on va essayer de voir justement comme on
peut aider aussi
pas seulement les petites entreprises
parce qu'il ya déjà des ailes de là
dessus les artisans bien sûr mais aussi
les commerces de proximité
comment on peut les aider tout comme
l'agglomération aide les entreprises
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
on a fait un travail assez assez pointue
de prise de contact avec avant par
l'entreprise pour bien on va dire
prendre la température et pour
identifier difficulté avant qu'elle
n'apparaisse est idéal l'entreprise sur
le territoire évidemment qui souffrent
beaucoup
évidemment l'événementiel et le tourisme
mais aussi deux secteurs on va dire
qu'ils sont majeurs pour le
l'agglomération je pense à l'automobile
et il est vrai qu'il y ait des
difficultés importantes qui se font
ressentir dans les grands comptes et qui
du coup effectivement aussi qui peuvent
atteindre
et bien tout est sous traitants et les
pme du territoire qui oeuvrent dans la
même filière pour soutenir chacune de
ces entreprises des dispositifs ont été
mises en place mais je pense par exemple
à ce nouveau dispositif qu'on a mis en
place à la région que celle disposition
de toute une entreprise de saint quentin
en yvelines qui est le pré rebonds qui
permet aux entreprises de se refinancer
avec des prêts allant de dix mille à
300000 euros pour les entreprises de
petite taille pour les pme sans garantie
sans cautionnement tous les acteurs
économiques peuvent en bénéficier
agriculteurs professionnels de la santé
mais aussi des secteurs de la culture et
du tourisme pour faciliter la reprise
d'activité le territoire élaboré le
guide des entrepreneurs
dispositions légales juridique ou
obligations de l'employeur
ils sont référencés ainsi que des
mesures de protection et le retour des
salariés sur le lieu du travail une fois
par semaine le ski cube propose de
suivre gratuitement des webinaires pour
faire le point sur les dernières mesures
en vigueur
côté sauvegarde de l'emploi
le territoire travaillent déjà à limiter
la hausse du chômage annoncée sur le
plan national il ya un sujet sur lequel
l'agglomération de cinq ans pour les
vignes avait beaucoup investi et qui à
mon avis sera sujet important de cette
période à venir c'est la formation
professionnelle qui va permettre
évidemment de reconverti aussi un
certain nombre de salariés de les
accompagner
6-6 se retrouve en licenciement pour
motif économique puisque c'est parce que
la loi prévoit dans ce cas là alors il
ya des m'accompagne mans qui sont
prévues notamment les gens profitent
pour pour le dire si jamais certains
sont déjà à ces difficultés là il ya le
contrat de sécurisation professionnelle
qui propose dans ce cas là qui permet
parfois de maintenir ses revenus et
aussi de se former et donc la nouvelle
agglomération là beaucoup investi sur la
formation
je pense aux métiers du numérique par
exemple sur lequel nous avions créé 300
places de formation et nous allons
continuer à le faire
[Musique]
depuis le 16 mars l'institut de
promotion de la santé à trappes est aux
côtés des professionnels de santé
il soutient aussi les plus fragiles
ainsi un dieu écoute jeunes a été mis en
place des points réguliers sont
effectués dans les maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires et les ehpad les
services de l'agglomération se sont
mobilisés pour proposer un
accompagnement et soutenir les aidants
les personnes en situation de précarité
notamment financières ou encore les
familles endeuillées
l'association solidum partenaires de
lits ps a développé le soli guide une
plate forme de cartographie des lieux
initiative et services aux personnes
vulnérables ou précaires nous tire au
sens l'aide alimentaire l'accompagnement
social ou encore les structures de santé
saint-quentinoise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autre service la collecte des déchets
celle des encombrants a repris les sept
déchetteries du territoire sont de
nouveau accessibles mais sur rendez vous
via le site internet
un seul dépôt par semaine sera possible
là encore gants et masques sont
obligatoires
[Musique]
ce qui m'a aidé c'est terminé n'oubliez
pas d'appliquer les gestes barrière
masque lavage des mains et distant à
très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]